okay I've got to talk about something
that I think some people aren't going to
like you know that on this show there
are no sacred cows right this is a
left-wing progressive show so a lot of
the criticisms are of right-wing ideas
and of right-wing people but there's no
short there's no short fall there's no
shortage of misguided left-wing ideas
and left-wing people and I call them out
I don't believe in tribalism that says
even if there are people on the Left who
are toxic or have bad ideas you can't
criticize them because they're part of
the same movement the same tribe the
same left-wing so last week we got a
live call as you know Pat we don't
screen live calls for topics people can
ask anything they want and a caller said
David what do you think about Jimmy Dore
who's now going to battle against Sam
cedar or Bernie aoc Andrew Gilliam Jill
um I don't even know how he says his
last name and I gave my opinion I gave
my opinion as I always do which was to
say in this case that I think Jimmy Dore
has become totally toxic I think he's a
useful idiot and a tool of really bad
movements and I got a ton of angry
emails and dislikes and even a handful
of people who had paid subscriptions to
the show who canceled them this is
really a concern it's a concern for me
but it's a concern for the left here's
an example email okay this is from
former member Jacqueline who said David
it's very disappointing that you have
opted to do an on-air attack to do on
air attacks on Jimmy Dore quote
completely toxic useful idiot and
dumb-dumb left were the choice words by
extension you are referring to his
audience as well which happens to
overlap with your audience sadly I was
foolish enough to pay the annual fee for
my Pakman membership which was valid
till next dot I still cancelled anyway
you can consider this hatred mail if you
so choose but that's not what it is by
having segments attacking other
progressives who aren't lockstep with
your views you are the one being toxic
this is one of a handful of people who
wrote me stuff like this and canceled
memberships so first of all just
consider the irony that they say I'm
being toxic by attacking a progressive
who's not in lockstep with my views by
canceling their memberships because I
think door is toxic they are attacking
me financially for not being in lockstep
with their views
sort of the same thing this is really
important okay don't miss the irony of
that but more importantly the left can't
be like this
okay there are bad ideas on the left and
right there are bad faith actors on the
left and right there are way more on the
right and we mostly focus on the ones on
the right but consider the opposite when
I get a call that says David what do you
think about the direction Jimmy Dore has
gone in my alternative instead of giving
you my honest opinion is to lie and say
he's doing great work would the audience
want me to lie and just say something
like that because of tribalism or so
that I don't anger certain people in the
audience I can't imagine that that's
what the audience wants and if the idea
is that I need to turn the show not into
what I genuinely think but instead into
what the leftist group think has
determined is better for quote the
movement that is a tribalistic disaster
so assuming you don't want me to lie to
you basically people who canceled
because I gave my honest opinion about
Jimmy are saying they're cancelling
because I have the wrong opinion and I
think that that's really dangerous
because as I've said before no two
people are going to agree on everything
ever right and if independent media is
going to survive and thrive which I
believe it needs to do okay
it can't depend on the financial support
that exists only up until there's a
disagreement on one issue right of
course people can choose to support me
or not support me for any reason right
or any other show for that matter but
this is why the right is succeeding in
so many ways they have made a commitment
where they say let's support people who
are basically on our side they might be
anti-gay but if there's a pro-gay rights
Republican who's mostly on their side
and helps their movement they support
that person they are anti-abortion but
if there's a pro-choice conservative
that's generally furthering I don't know
there's small government views or
they're low tax views or whatever they
support that person if this is how the
left is going to sit decide who we
support we're going to fail
okay and by the way if we apply the no
support if they say one wrong thing idea
what about all the people who were
supporting Jimmy Dore despite the fact
that he did at one point push seth rich
conspiracy theories if you don't buy
that stuff and i think most people in my
audience do not
wouldn't that be disqualifying of your
support for jimmy right so the main
point is let's not allow ourselves to be
ripped apart in this way and we can't do
this type of tribalism this type of
tribalism is going to destroy the
movement from the inside out if you
really think the problem is only
progressives making honest critiques of
other progressives when they feel
they're warranted and making critiques
of the right when those are warranted
that is not actually the problem and we
really need to think hard about what it
is that we're saying when you say i'm
pulling my support because i disagree
with you about this issue or that issue
or think that it should be off-limits to
criticize other progressive media i want
to hear from you about this